joining us now are stars of the hit
Bravo series Vanderpump Rules please
welcome bartending royalty Ariana and
Tom
[Applause]
see you all again
I love every time I see it because you
bring alcohol it's awesome
hi Paula big fans all right everybody is
a big fan of her she's so funny
um so um our aunt and Tom we've been
enjoying the classic margarita from your
book fancy AF cocktails and for the kids
at home a stands for and and the f is
for fun right
that's could possibly be anything you
should literally come out with a
children's book with like juices but do
like a different version Fancy and fun
cocktails I'm just saying okay Paula and
I have destroyed our Margaritas because
we are women
um who take our drinking seriously so do
you want to make another one yes
absolutely okay so for the classic
margarita everything's fresh you're
gonna drop in one lemon wedge one lime
wedge oh okay and then you're gonna take
half an ounce you can use the smaller
side of your half an ounce of
agave nectar and then give it a good
muscle okay oh modeling modeling yeah
okay so now what do we do now you're
gonna fill it to the top with ice and
then we add the alcohol yes
the best part okay so we're gonna make
six ounces of Blanco tequila that's the
larger side of the all the way
filled to the top
this one no the uh smaller or yeah with
that one we're gonna do a half uh okay
half ounce we're gonna have the orange
liqueur
add that to the Shaker
eyeball it toss it in yeah
all right and then we're just gonna
train right in our assaulted margarita
glass yeah spraying it right in there
okay
do you know what I look like Thumper
when I perform watch me the next time
before I literally I stomp one foot like
I'm like I don't know
I didn't put enough tequila in it so I'm
just gonna
um
[Applause]
I totally poured over my my
whatever it is okay let's taste it
cheers cheers love it cheers guys that
is so good I made a good margarita y'all
who knew
what is this one there's another drink
over here okay so this classic margarita
is perfect for Cinco de Mayo yeah this
is our perfect or fresh start Margarita
which is perfect for say demaio it's a
recovery mocktail that's gonna help you
after the all-day Fiesta and there are
some fancy mixers in there that are
going to help nurse you back to health
yeah so there's uh there's honey
lavender uh syrup ginger syrup all which
you can buy on Amazon and then you add
water ice and the secret ingredient
lemon and lime Alka-Seltzer which is
great for post celebration heartburn and
headache yeah this tastes really good it
is
forehead
cradles you like a little baby the next
one I like both I'm just you're gonna
catch me at the next place I go just
double fisting you got the one I'm gonna
I'm gonna go and then repair and then
and then repair all right so you guys
took a trip to Turks and Caicos I love
Turks and Caicos uh what was your first
day together like and was it like the
video
it's crazy very even full yeah I'm from
the plane right there yeah like oh my
God before you got there yeah before we
got there a certain someone
um oh my God oh my God people out of
their name so it was like right away
fireworks look at the smile as you're
saying it oh my God
I know I know God bless your heart
definitely some words uh on the plane
and there were f-bombs flying on the G
yeah
collection rooms although we all live in
beautiful homes we'll be going trips
together we turn into like animals when
it's time to like who gets the best room
and all those things it's crazy and
someone
broke the rules and
got her room before she's supposed to I
mean have you guys not seen it look at
her shoes
she's famous she always runs to the
first room the best friend that's true
we gave Kenya the best room I know
nobody didn't no we didn't
we played a game
oh I got the red star I got the Redstone
was already in a room in fact naked on
the bed yeah oh my God
is it true that you and Kenya had issues
though the first day absolutely oh my
gosh the first day before we took off
the first before we actually took off on
the plane yeah we'll let them watch the
show very soon
wow well I think it was the part when
Ramona said
I guess we can say okay I came in peace
best teaser oh my God I love it she's
like I am the victim
our show is conflict and resolution you
have to see if we if you work it out
made resolution on our conflict okay I
think
we're sitting here you're doing fine
um so okay let's let's go down the line
with some rapid fire questions
um who took the longest to get ready for
dinner Cynthia you start uh Kenya
all right so next rapid fire question so
we we all hear about the glamor like you
said
um but in a sentence what's the most
challenging thing about being a part of
this franchise I'll start with you oh
I'm gonna start with you I was trying to
be rapid fire right yeah last question
no no yeah no outfits because you know
really we when you film you don't
realize how many clothes you really do
need um well Teresa what about you
um the most challenging thing
um you know I have to say I always say
like I on my other show the New Jersey
Housewives yeah like I really didn't
enjoy being on that show
um I love being on the show like you
know we it was all about women
empowerment and like you know it wasn't
about like taking anyone down or
anything like that we I feel like we
lifted each other up I mean listen there
was shade thrown at each other but you
know it was all good I mean so you know
I love putting on it I would have to
agree with Teresa I think one of the
hardest things it's definitely on
Atlanta is just being able to you know
you have the bond you have The
Sisterhood but just being able to keep
the friendship intact because it's very
difficult yeah to be in a group of women
and you know if you know if someone's
coming for you they're coming for you
and then you're like okay where are my
friends well you know what's going on
it's just a lot of it's not an easy not
an easy thing to do it's very easy to
watch which I enjoy watching everyone
all of you guys on your show and not
being a part of it anymore but um yeah
it's it's tough it's important in the
public eye as well yeah being the part
of the franchise and getting back to
work what's the biggest challenge which
is you know is people judging you all
the time you know and we're just women
who are trying to juggle everything you
know we've got families and we've got
you know the other husbands friends
the one you know we're trying to date
you know we've got you know children and
work and yeah we do the best we can and
we just want to have a good time and and
we want people to go along for the ride
and have a good time with us you know
and and go through the struggles that
everybody in this audience I'm sure can
relate to that we all go through you
know yeah yeah but I think none of us
mentioned which is really one thing
could happen that's not good if you
think you're really good friends with
someone and then they do the interviews
they say something really nasty or Shady
behind your back and you watch it for
the first time you go why would you say
that like yeah my show all the time
you're like wait what yeah yeah wait
yeah you said what yeah what yeah that's
that hurts yeah what can fans expect
this season on Vanderpump Rules oh my
goodness even when I see the trailer I
think it's so complicated it moves so
quickly I think people have really
invested in the show so you know just to
see these people struggle to grow up you
know it's been eight years now and uh
just to see how things moved on the more
things change made more they stay the
same there's that kind of old expression
I still think you see that incredibly
complicated convoluted dynamic between
this group of friends but that's what
makes it fun to watch as well as
poignant as well as you know the
cohesion between the group and I think
essentially a great reality show is one
that's based on authenticity and
Vanderpump Rules is it's a great season
yeah well Vanderpump Rules bands are
some of the most dedicated I know tons
of them so no matter what they see on
the show they always want more the fans
want more so we're going to do something
we call audience ask oh Lord Eddie there
you go so where is Leticia Ohio
oh thank you I know Leticia can sing I
heard her on commercial breaks so what
do you want to ask Lisa so uh Kelly so
nice to meet you Lisa nice to meet you
Andy and puffy what's good
um so the question I had for you is if
you had to be locked in a room with any
of the real Housewives who would it be
and what would you talk about to make
the time pass wow my goodness that's not
fair things I just left oh it could be
from any of the friends it could be from
any of the franchise um I think probably
Bethany but I probably wouldn't have to
discuss anything with her because I
wouldn't get a word in Edgewood is
because
yeah amazing yeah so probably Bethany
that's awesome well thank you Leticia
yeah thank you people want to know that
we have another question here we go
where is Brenna Brenna hi Brenna thank
you
um so I actually have two questions okay
um Rudy but okay
the first one is um do you think that
stassi and Kristen are going to be able
to mend things well I think
fundamentally there's been a difference
between them I mean I try not to weigh
in on this too much personally because
I've always found Christian who
difficult to get on with myself but I
think this year as stars has grown up
they both have grown up I have to say
she's got a book deal now Chris Stern
and stars is you know getting married
and she's been on the best seller list
so they're both growing up but I think
the Dubai just got wider and wider and I
don't know but there's years of History
so I'm hopeful because it's a shame to
break up such a long friendship but I
don't know this season it was very bumpy
very bumpy fingers crossed yeah yeah all
right what's the second question and
then what do you think the deal is with
Jack's unfollowing everybody is he
trying to strike I cannot spill that one
because that kind of comes at the end of
the the season oh she's trying to get
you yeah you are like yeah she's working
for exactly I can't give that away
otherwise I will be in but you know Jax
he's a very complicated complicated
character he sounds fun
that is bad
so thank you so much Brenna even you're
too much though it was great I have to
talk about this I have to talk about
Housewives so I heard that you and Erica
had like a little thing but y'all are
good now well you know she was upset
okay when you start with whoa I know
exactly no we actually are good okay
there were things in the show that she
saw over the season obviously that hurt
her feelings you know and you know we
had a lot of questions it was very
confusing and then there was a scene
where my husband and PK were like kind
of like laughing and then okay they make
me laugh and it's hard it's like when
you're in church or something you're not
supposed to laugh and then you you know
you can't help it yeah I left in
inappropriate times right and so that
was kind of the thing and I knew oh gosh
when she sees that she's going to be
upset and
so but we you know we work through
things on the reunion yeah that's hard
like with yeah friendships in general
are hard when you're filming Halloween
was hard and scary deal with these women
for a day
real grind so wait so you let your
classmates sudden stay with you recently
it's a tricky thing when you let friends
say so like what happened how did that
go well she was supposed to lease my
house for me for a month and she ended
up being there almost a year sorry
something that's truth and then and then
you know you know she was a great tenant
though I have to say I was happy to have
her there and I loved it and then she'd
sent me an email one day and she was
like you know there is a black widow
spider in the garage and I was like just
burn the house down because I do not
like a spider and I think she took my
email a little too seriously but we
addressed the situation on the reunion
too so everybody wants to tune in they
can find out oh my God your house was
only set up for okay here's the thing
I'm from Texas too there's like spiders
everywhere
I'd rather an alligator than a spider I
think we you are messed up
you have a chance at winning with one
well the spiders you can get little
places you don't know about and they can
be deadly that's what I don't like um I
just like to be bigger than the other
thing that's my that's my general
account
I can't wrestle I'm like Crocodile
Dundee or anything so you you have some
baby news congrats yes thank you
this is another big addition to the
family
um a lot of people may or may not know
that I had issues getting pregnant you
know when me and my husband got married
so we had did the IVF treatment and we
got our son Ace yeah he's three now and
we wanted to have another Chow we still
had two more embryos from that and
because I had a high risk pregnancy you
know we were trying to figure out okay
what's the best way to go about this and
we decided to go with a surrogate yeah
and she decided to help me and my
husband that's amazing I loved it
because you're you're actually
documenting it on this show right yes
and I think that's really important I
have many friends that have suffered
from like trying to have children trying
trying and can't do it and like it's a
very important thing to be confident and
comfortable saying like look my body it
wasn't made for my body by the way was
not made for pregnancy I was
hospitalized it was horrible oh my God
Bless surrogates yeah
also not made
hahaha
it's it's a heart if your body if it
doesn't take it is like so hard on you
so it's it's an amazing thing I think
it's so awesome that you're like sharing
that that's okay when you go into the
will you be there for the delivery oh
yeah
for sure I mean that's a lot of what
you'll see on the show this season like
you'll see we're going to doctor's
appointments together we're you know
just that whole process because I don't
think anybody actually showed it because
a lot of people are quiet about it like
honestly I really didn't even tell
anybody that we were expecting a child
into the show announced that it was
airing a new season because I didn't
really know how to share that with a lot
of my friends even like a lot of my
friends were like wait a minute you
having a baby you know yeah it was like
really crazy to them but at the same
time I didn't really want to hear
anybody else's opinion at first yeah and
so to do it to you yeah to do it on the
show it's like a big deal because it's
like you don't know how people are going
to comment
um because you know the first thing
you're getting a beautiful child who the
hell cares what they that is true
exactly yeah good point
your state like honestly I like that is
a really touchy subject with a lot of my
friends that's like really hard like for
a woman especially like you it's such a
sense of failure you feel like when you
can't do it so it's really cool that
you're open about it thank you the with
my first job my um Riley's you know it
was in my 20s you know I didn't have to
really try hard but then you know later
in life when I met my husband I'm
thinking that everything was just gonna
happen and it didn't so I think you know
a lot of women start to have that
struggle as they get older mm-hmm yeah I
didn't have my kids I was in my 30s it
was oh and I didn't ever look like that
um so you're how you're also I found out
you're a big fan of Real Housewives what
draws you in
I love the the drama and my wife I told
my wife she would be great on your show
but we really
yeah does she bring a lot of drama she
is very well I'm dramatic but her
reactions are always dramatic but she
couldn't do it because we live here in
La she'd be late for every episode
the commute was rough well you know you
have the Housewives of Beverly Hills out
here and they would love you guys she
would be the housewife of Atlanta that's
the one that's right
it's the one it's not even the character
she just loves the town
I do love Atlanta yeah I do yeah so does
the conflict like ever and or is it
always that like high stress and do you
have to like
I would need like a lot of wine like
that's a lot of like you know but you
know what sometimes those girls on my
show they get a lot of wine and that's
when they act up oh that's when they act
up I always say the drinking does not
work in this group of girls but no this
season is really really good like you
know I'm really excited about it because
um not only do we have the drama which
That Never Ends but we also have like so
much personal story happening with each
woman on the show but do you ever regret
you ever like because you guys are so
open then there's so much drama and it's
real and you could tell it's not
produced do you ever like tape something
or something then you go oh my I can't
believe I said that you've got to cut
that out and then they don't understand
we have definitely and I have definitely
said things on that show that I'm like
oh you know I just let it go I've
threatened to drag a couple people on
the show that was a few seasons back you
know but the real question is did they
deserve it no I'm just kidding
exactly you know whenever you um have
one of those moments where you explode
and you didn't you weren't able to
control your temper I didn't know what
you speak of
the moment where you like oh God I'm
gonna look crazy in front of the world
you know and you're afraid that you know
afraid of how the world is going to
accept it but at the end of the day I
just always tell people you know if you
had a camera following you you know five
days out of the week and you're having
to deal with people that you don't
necessarily get along with and they're
constantly pressing your buttons you
know they they would catch something you
know that's the stuff people you know
really you know keeps gratitude towards
yeah they like the drama don't they fly
in demand I have had enough drama
[Applause]
okay so wait you're a fan favorite on um
Real Housewives but your first season is
almost done
um so would you come back would you do
it again
well we first have to see if I'm invited
back oh I I'm inviting you back to the
show
I have no say but I think you should go
back to the shuttle this Friday we do
the reunion so between
that
and then meeting you I did not sleep
last night by the way I love you so much
I have vaseline in my mouth and on my
teeth and my hands are freezing I love
it and it's because of you in the
reunion oh my gosh and so awesome that's
so nice to know wait but
ton should be fun right the reunion will
be fun but what I'm trying to say is
about two weeks after the reunion we
find out if we're invited back man they
keep you going on yeah they keep you
okay I mean I would love to yeah you
loved it a lot of fun yeah
and escape the queens of r b so candy
could you tell us what happens on this
new show well
um you know we were just really
following the Journey of two strong
female groups of the 90s and showing you
you know the behind the scenes of what
it takes to make a show like this
happens so you just get to follow that
Journey you get to see what happened in
our personal lives and then you know
obviously we're too strong female group
yeah so you can see how sometimes you
know we do not not necessarily see eye
to eye but yeah figure it out I think it
would be a lie if y'all did like nobody
you know what I'm saying like especially
with that many like bold women like it's
like yeah personality is like it's like
if you're an Entertainer in general like
that many artists in in one place like
nobody's going to agree on everything
but I love the fact that you prove that
it can happen like even though we don't
have to always agree on stuff but it can
still come to fruition I mean I think
that's the the strength of being in a
group period it's like a lot of times we
don't necessarily agree but we want our
fans to be happy so at the end of the
day we're going to figure it out to get
on that stage and pull that show
together so that our fans can be happy
because we love our fans we love the
support they give us even if we go crazy
backstage yeah we're going to do what we
got to do to make that show right yeah
it's more than us you know it's more
than the performer it's about them I
agree I agree well tiny the idea to
perform together came from doing verses
right yes this was during coven yes yeah
yeah we had one of the dopest verses
ever I feel
you know it's a platform where two
different artists or writers and they
come together producers and they play
hit for hit you know they just do it's
like a little friendly battle but that's
what started the whole idea of us maybe
like joining and doing more you know on
the road or a show so Latasha you've
said that you you were not excited about
this tour why is that well in the
beginning it was that we had like Kinks
to iron out right and so when you go
through those types of things you never
want to bring somebody else in it's like
having a family dinner right and you're
everybody's having fun also we get at us
and then you invite someone else over
and it's like they're that's unfair to
them oh I've been to many of those yeah
no and that's just not what it is it
talked about Survivor this was our
survivor yeah yeah without the bugs yeah
is that hard like being family and
having to like talk about stuff like
that on air
you know I mean but this is our truth
you know what I mean so we go through
things and I think that this is shed
light on other families that are looking
siblings that are saying oh they got
through that or this is how they work
this out yeah Survivor I love survivors
yeah yeah that's a lot of families so
Tamika a sisters um Yul Natasha don't
always get along as we were just saying
so do you feel like it's hard for you
personally to because I know that me and
my sister are very different like she's
more private than I am I am like what
you want to know like you know and I
probably should shut my mouth but like
I'm like one of those people I'm just a
total extrovert right so is it is it
hard for you to like sometimes it's hard
just not just me and my sister but all
of us like sisters yeah but it you know
the misconception is we're arguing but
we just talk loud when we talk so I mean
we have no argument yeah we have a loud
conversation yeah and even if you do
argue that's okay like I feel like if
you don't then you're never gonna have
progress and you're never going to own
your real
I love it could have been a lawyer so uh
Lily this year is the 30th anniversary
of SWV so how have y'all managed to get
that's amazing
how have you managed to stay together
like that's you know what I'm saying
just pull in together constantly oh my
God
sometimes we don't yeah you know but you
know it this that we have such amazing
fans and sometimes the journey is more
important than the problem yeah and I
think that's what that's why we're here
today as well as Escape you know we love
each other but sometimes what sister you
know that you don't have a fight where
you don't have a problem with it's
normal you know but we are stronger
together than we are apart amen and
we've grown so much we've grown over the
years yeah
we were young we were teenagers yeah our
journey we were learning lessons as we
went along and sometimes we just we're
getting it right in the public yeah you
know we're growing in the public so
that's what you guys seeing we've
learned to respect one another yeah
because we didn't always respect one
another
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
yeah
I'm going
thank you